معنا الان مشاهدينا من دبي الشيف ناديه
السيد اهلا بك شيف ناديه معنا في صباح
العربيه
اهلا راويه اهلا عادل طيب يا ناديه بدون
خزعبلات انا عجبتني هاي الكلمه ودلالتها
بدون خزعبلات الاشياء الدخيله على المطبخ
الاصيل ما بدنا اياها خبرينا اكثر عن طيب
يعني انت كيف هل كيف ممكن تطوري من
الوصفات اللي عندك بدون ما تدخلي خزعبلات
زي ما سميتيها
هو انا لفت نظري بس ان انا اول ما بدات
انه يعني المقصود بدون مكونات خزعبليه
بدون طرق صعبه يعني انه في بعض الشفات
علشان يثبتوا مهارتهم او علشان يثبتوا ان
هم يعني متماسين بيحطوا بهارات غريبه او
بيعملوا الوصفه بخطوات صعبه فبالتالي يعني
بتخليها صعبه على الناس هو للاسف يعني ده
كان دارج لفتره معينه فانا قررت ان انا
لما اعمل قناه او اما اعمل وصفات يعني
بالمعنى المحلي كده ما تفازلكش يعني
الوصفه على اصلها زي ما هي كده اهي من غير
فزلك علشان ما ابينش ان انا فاهمه وان انا
شيف بقى مفيش مني يعني ما تكررت بعملها
على اصولها الاكل نفس
وذائقه زي ما بيقولوا لما حد يدخل بهارات
تركيا ولا يدخل بهارات صينيه ولا من ايا
كان ما هذا المطابخ العالميه
تندمج وتعطيك ذائقه مختلفه ليه لا
[موسيقى]
بس تعمل حاجه جديده ما تبقاش هي نفس
الوصفه يعني بنعمل بقى وصفه جديده حاجه
نديها اسم جديد
بدائقه مختلفه بالدائقه الصينيه يعني
عندهم الكميتشي بس عاملينه بطريقه عندهم
مثلا حاجه اه اللي هو الخاص وعندهم حاجات
كثيره يعني شبه شويه الحاجات اللي عندنا
بس مستحيل ان احنا ندمج حاجتين ونسميها
بالوصف الشرقي بتاعنا يعني احنا لا عندنا
مثلا الملوخيه بتاعتنا خلاص هي ملوخيه او
صينيه البطاطس زي ما قلت مش هنحط عليها
صويا صوص او عسل عشان تبقى سويته نصور
يعني هنعملها بطريقتها عايزين بقى نفتكز
هنعمل بطاطس بشكل مختلف وده اللي انا
بقوله لهم هنعمل النهارده بطاطس بشكل
مختلف طيب خلينا خلينا احنا حابين ناديه
الجديده تعطينا امثله يعني انه مثلا هذا
الطبق هو طبق تقليدي انا بعمله بهذه
الطريقه اللي هي طريقه اصليه خلينا نشوف
اكثر
وعلشان لانه يعني نثبت لعادل بانه الكبسه
بالبهارات المكسيكيه ما بتنفع
بتركب كبسه مكسيكيه ردي علي
لانوي مفيش لا لا يمكن ابدا ده انا اعتزل
الطبخ
خليني عشان ما ندخلش مع بعض خلينا
بسبوس الكويتي انا في مره من المرات شفت
احد الشيفات يحط له
الباربكيوسوس وهذا يعني غريب
خزعبلات دي انا مقدرش اتكلم على على حد
عمل حاجه اهو الخزعبل اه خزعبل طب خلينا
نشوف ما هو ليس خزعت على فكره
النهارده يلا تفضلي
خليني اقول لكم انا طبخه النهارده عامله
شوربه المشروم بالكريمه بالطريقه بتاعتها
اللي هي الاصليه من غير اي افتكاسات
نحمر التوم
ونحمر ونقطع المشروم ببلا مشروم اللي هو
الابيض او البني
والشوربه المشروم بيتحط عليها زعتر حط بس
معلقه صغيره كده من الزعتر ورشه من الملح
والفلفل الاسود فقط ما فيش حاجه ثالثه هو
ملح وفلفل اسود ورشه من الزعتر بس
وبناخد بقى ايه اه بس كده خلاص المارش ما
احنا عايزين نحس طعشر بناخذ جزء من
المشروم طبعا انا عملته قبل قبل
ما ابتدي بناخذ جزء من المشروم نفسه
الصحيح مع الشوربه اللي طلعت وبنطحنه انا
طحنته بقى عامل زي البيوري كده هوت وده
بقى بنزله كدهوت في شوربه المشروم بتاعتنا
بيديها بقى طعم خزعبل يعني ايه بتبقى سهله
لانها مشروم في مشروم
تركز الوضع تاكلي شفت مارشم بره بتلاقيها
طعمها مشروم قوي علشان هم بيطحنوا المشروم
وبيحطوه بقى مع مع يعني كل معلقه فيها طعم
مشروم وطبعا بنحط عليها كريمه او حليب
كامل الدسم او قشطه بس طبعا هو الافضل
طبعا كريمه هنا بقى انا ممكن اقول
للمتابعين بتوعي مثلا يستبدلوها بحليب
كامل الدسم نحط كريمه على الشوربه طبعا
بتديها غنى وبتديها دسم حلو جدا وتاخد لها
غلوتين وخلاص الموضوع انتهى كده اهدي
شوربه المشروم وطعمها يعني
رهيب بجد لازم انا اجيبها لكم واجب
من المؤسسه
للمقبلات او الشغل
او الطبقه الرئيسي شو عم شو محضرتي لنا
شيف ناديه
عامله لكم سالمون
ناس كثير يعني بتحب السلمون طب سلمى
السلمون بيتحط عليه مثلا الاناناس بيعطيه
وطعم مختلف
ممكن ممكن يتحط عليه ممكن يتلاقي فيه
الزبده المكرمله يعني جبت الزبده وكملتها
لما اخدت لهم كراميش شايفين اللون وحطيت
عليها التوم وجنزبيل مفرومين وبعد كده ربع
كوبايه من العسل الابيض ممكن سكر بني عادي
برده نفس المذاق
بنحمر بقى السلم ونسيبه بقى ايه على نار
هاديه بقى وبصوا بقى مش عايزه اقول لكم
الريحه عامله ازاي جوعتيها
عمليه
انا نفسي بس اغرفه بسرعه كده
انا لازم اجيب لكم الاكل واجي دلوقتي طيب
ليه يعني هذا مع العسل السالمون في الاخير
تحطي عليه العسل ولا من البدايات اه مع
العسل
من الاول قبل ما هو ينزل هينزل في العسل
والتوم والجنزبيل نقدر نستبدل العسل
بالسكر ولا صعبه
كرمالايس لا ممكن لا مش
كبير ولا عادل طلع خبير يعني بقى انا اقدر
النعمه واحب معدتي صحتين
بس لمونه كده شاف ناديه معنا دقيقه ما
بعرف اخر حاجه
اخر طبق هو قوالب الباذنجان خليني اجيبها
هنا قوالب الباذنجان بالمارينارا صوص
والريحان البتنجان بس بنكهه ايطاليه ازاي
بقى ما قلناش مسقعه قلنا بتنجان يعني
مطبوخ بتنجان مطبوخ مع طماطم وفلفل مع مع
ثوم مع بهارات ايطاليه زي الاورجانو ويتحط
على الوش كده شويه موتزاريلا وريحان مشوي
ولا مقلي يعني خفيف خالص
مشوي الفرن
اتشوى في الفرن
مناظر تشهي يعني
على فكره هذا من عذاب الارواح يعني خلينا
نعترف
طب ان شاء الله
ههه
بس خليني خليني اقول لك انه انا وسام جايب
زميلنا وسام بما انه يقدر ايضا هو المعده
التي تهضم وانا وجاي لك من غير راويه
انا جوعت برضه
ليه طيب
بس خليني عندنا عشرين ثانيه اي اكثر طبق
مقرب الى قلبك
محشي الكرنب محشي يا الله
لا لا لا هي بتقدر
شكرا شيف ناديه شكرا جزيلا لك
يعطيك العافيه وان شاء الله نشوفك مستقبلا
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات